welcome back to the David Pakman show I
am fair and cousin sitting in for David
Pakman today let's talk about policy for
a little bit here you know we've got two
major policies that could horribly
affect the United States happening right
now one of which is actually already
horribly affecting the United States and
that happens to be Donald Trump's trade
war now this past weekend Fox News ran
an op-ed on their website by Andy
puzzlers and in this op-ed mr. Posner
decides to go after the Democrats
running for president for being
completely backwards on trade allegedly
here's a few quotes out of this this is
absolutely craziness here what mr.
Puzder writes he says Trump's opponents
accused him of starting a dangerous
trade war with China China but in
reality China has been waging economic
war against the US for decades President
Trump just decided it was time for
America to start fighting back by
fighting back does he mean file for
bankruptcy and an alarming rate because
that's what's happening to our farming
farming communities thanks to the donald
trump's trade wars does he mean that
people are contemplating suicide in this
country because of the effect these
trade wars are having on their
businesses their livelihoods their life
because that's also happening those
reports started coming out last week
people's lives are being destroyed
because of these trade wars and these
republican cheerleaders like the ones on
fox news who say heck yeah stick it to
china they don't understand what's
actually happening because none of it
affects them there isn't a single person
working on the air on fox news who is
affected by this trade war by any of the
tariffs whatsoever they're not having to
pay a price consumers our average
american citizens our small business
owners our large business owners are but
not Fox and that's why they're able to
sit out there talk about things they
don't understand
and I'm going to get to that in just a
second but act as cheerleaders for the
president's horrendous policies
and here's what I mean when I say they
don't understand most people don't
understand trade deficits they don't
understand the economics of trade it is
believe it or not an incredibly complex
system that most economists will tell
you doesn't matter at all and that may
come as a shock to hear but I spent the
last 48 hours researching this looking
to see if I could find credible
economists who were willing to come out
and say that yes trade deficits matter
they hurt our country and we have to do
something about it and I couldn't do it
couldn't find it you know why because it
doesn't exist you're not going to find a
credible economist who tells you that
yeah we've got to do something about our
trade imbalance with China and yet here
we have an administration that's been
telling us for well over a year that
China has been playing us all for
suckers that they have been taking
advantage of us is what President Trump
has specifically said China's been
taking advantage of us and he's fighting
back let me ask you the audience this
question and I asked my own audience
this question last week and could not
get a single response so please if you
do have a response to this feel free
reach out to me on Twitter at fair and
balanced DM me tweet it at me and tell
me when you have personally felt
victimized by the trade imbalance
between the US and China Trump told us
we were being victimized they were
taking advantage of us and that it was
impacting us so tell me a personal
experience you have had buying a good or
service when you've walked away being
just D'Arnot I was done the victim here
China screwed me again again my Twitter
feed is wide open please if that has
happened to you let me know at Ferren
balanced I want to hear honest to god I
want to hear if that has happened to you
but you know what I'm willing to bet it
hasn't an economist would agree with me
because here's the thing yes when you
only look at bilateral trade and you see
a 300 billion dollar trade imbalance
because we're taking more from China
than they're taking from us on paper
that looks bad but also on paper it
really doesn't matter it doesn't
technically affect the US economy in any
significant way there there might be
small things here and there that do get
affected yes economists admit that but
beyond that is there are large scale
ramifications for it no it doesn't exist
and plus once you start to look at the
bigger picture because this isn't just
the US and China doing business together
and everybody else just stays within
their borders this is a global economy
so we may have a trade imbalance with
China and we may have a trade surplus
with another country who has a trade
surplus with China but China has a
surplus with us but it all eventually
evens out and yes overall the trade
deficit we may still be down but if our
economy is doing well then it doesn't
matter when our economy is doing poorly
you could make the argument that we
should reduce the trade deficit but
ultimately economists also agree that
that's really not going to do anything
to help our economy we are not being
victimized we are not being taken
advantage of with soybeans and steel the
one area that they say that China has
you know kind of screwed the US over on
is patent infringement and copyright law
you know taking our ideas most of that
has to do with military stuff
fighter jets things like that other
countries have also come in and said
China's actually hacked them to steal
their trade secrets so that they can
build tanks and planes and bombs and
whatnot so yes we do have an issue with
that
but putting tariffs on steel coming into
the u.s. from China that's not gonna do
that it's not gonna fix it it's not even
going to address the problem the
President himself has yet to address the
real problem
but instead wants to pass on the
billions of dollars each month in
tariffs to American citizens now at this
point I don't know if the president is
just playing stupid or if he is honestly
just ignorant about how these tariffs
work but American citizens are paying
those American businesses are paying
those we're the ones who are suffering
we're the ones who are having our
businesses closed their doors big and
small by the way our farmers who Trump
just announced he was going to give
another twelve to fifteen billion dollar
bailout they're struggling and the first
bailout he announced most of it didn't
even go to them they didn't know what to
do they didn't know how to handle it so
the money just kind of sat there sure
they bought a bunch of crops that they
couldn't sell that the farmers couldn't
sell but that's about it
we need to work together with the World
Trade Organization to prevent China from
being a bad actor that's the truth okay
but you're not going to get there with a
trade war it simply isn't gonna happen
there are no winners in the trade wars
just billions of losers and right now
there's a few hundred million losers in
the United States who are the ones
suffering the real effects from Donald
Trump's trade wars because as you'll
notice he hasn't put tariffs on any of
the goods that he and his family produce
over there he's remained unscathed it's
just everything else that American
citizens like to buy or use that he's
screwing us over on but don't worry you
want to buy a Trump good it's gonna be
just as cheap now as it ever was